hello my name is Karen warden I'm with
la talk radio skill courage we're here
at the 6th annual San Diego indie fest
I'm here with mr. Kurt Ron is a
production designer didn't tell us any
additional insights you had after you
did today's panel well one of the things
that we you know had not discussed on
the panel at all really was a technical
thing of you know how green screen and
CG is influencing actual production and
I think even the titles I just got done
doing a piece for the world expo that
they listed me as the production
designer well most of the production
design was done already by somebody else
at a computer screen I just brought in
the green screen elements the skeleton
pieces that they later covered with the
skins and everything so I'm really gonna
have any of the design actual to that
project those of those already
previously decided and you know green
screen is changing its changing the
world of the art directors changing the
world of production design you know it
used to be the maze all saying was you
know the look of the overall look of
everything else around the actors and
you you know you wanted your work to be
seen in context with the story on you
deal with green screen it's about your
work not being seen you're like I said
creating these skeletons and you don't
you don't want your work to be screened
seen and it's in when you're doing a
low-budget film it's something to take
into consideration I did a
low-end commercial with that Rustler and
Goldberg and we actually shot this in
his garage and from a 20-foot green
screen I saw the composite and they had
put him on the stage that it would have
been sixty eighty a hundred thousand
dollars to build that stage live and I'm
sure the cost of doing it imposed or you
know computer generator was probably
like maybe only twenty thirty thousand
and these these are things in that are
available to the line you know filmmaker
the low-budget filmmakers is a I heard
of somebody in i believe is sweden or
something that had actually done like an
episode of star wars over a year and a
half period of time in their apartment
but you look at this thing and it looks
like something that has reduced its
amazing Sam yeah and I think that
technological end is something that we
really do